arles et arnaud benedetti rédacteur en
chef de la revue politique et
parlementaire bonsoir nos benedetti
merci d'être avec nous que les stents
bien qu'ils remportent dont aucun la
favorite à la primaire populaire jean
luc mélenchon yannick jadot anne hidalgo
qui ne reconnaissent pas le le vote tout
ça pour ça et on tenté de dire que que
peut-il se passer maintenant
pas grand chose si ce n'est que la
primaire populaire qui devait aux yeux
de ses initiateurs être un outil qui
permette le rassemblement de la gauche
va déboucher sur une candidature
supplémentaire comble alors appelé les
autres candidats à gauche depuis
maintenant plusieurs jours donc la
question qui se pose c'est de savoir
si aujourd'hui celle qui est la
candidate sociale-démocrate c'est à dire
madame hidalgo je crois que c'est la
question d'ailleurs essentiel peut-être
qu'ils se posent aujourd'hui à gauche va
pouvoir
continuer à conduire une campagne avec
des intentions de vote qui sont au
dessous de 5% avec le risque si ces
intentions de vote étaient confirmées
par le street art du village reid de
voir un parti socialiste se retrouver en
grande difficulté financière et surtout
en grande difficulté pour négocier au
moment des élections légistatives parce
que finalement la candidature de madame
toubib vient aussi d'une certaine
manière mordre sur les sur les marchés
si je puis dire de madame hidalgo en
tout cas elle elle dit anne hidalgo
qu'elle ira jusqu'au bout elle le dit
depuis le début pour autant la lumière
de ce que vous venez de nous expliquer
ce que sa position est intenable
les grands les grands fondateurs du
parti
socialiste seront ceux qui à un moment
donné
montrons que non si jusque finalement le
maintien
en l'état de madame hidalgo dans les
semaines qui viennent mais en péril la
vieille maison comme aurait dit léon
blum d'une certaine manière parce que si
vous voulez les conséquences pour parti
socialiste d'une candidate qui est au
dessous de 5% sur les conséquences que
je viens de décrire mais c'est surtout
la question de la survie même du parti
socialiste qui est en jeu qui est un
parti qui quand même dispose d'un réseau
d'élus qui dispose de grandes régions
qui disposent de grandes mairies madame
ida clos faut-il le rappeler est maire
de paris donc disons le parti socialiste
ne peut pas se payer le luxe d'un échec
aussi magistrale lors d'une élection
présidentielle ça voudrait dire que
madame hidalgo serait hors de sa du
secours qui était pourtant déjà
cruellement bas de monsieur hamon
alentours de minuit en tout cas renommée
les betis est primé almées de faire
parler de la gauche parce que c'est vrai
qu'elle était un petit peu invisible
pendant cette ce début de campagne
qui selon vous semble tirer le plus son
épingle du jeu
globalement à gauche et ignace à ce
stade à ce stade c'est celui qui
apparaît comme le plus différenciant et
peut-être le plus expérimenté malgré
parfois un certain nombre d'explosions
de caractère qui lui ont certainement
nui dans l'opinion publique c'est jean
luc mélenchon aujourd'hui jean luc
mélenchon est elle un étiage qui est de
l'ordre de 9 10% alors un peu inférieur
à celui qui était le sien peut être à la
même époque en 2010 est en tout cas
manifestement c'est lui qui se détache
pour l'instant par contre après bon
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué on à
monsieur jadot qui essayent tant bien
que mal lui aussi de faire disons vivre
la voie de l'écologie dans cette
campagne dans un contexte difficile
parce que jadot est sur une ligne
politique qui n'est pas une ligne
politique clairement majoritaire au sein
des verts et même au sein de l'électorat
des verts et il est aussi d'une certaine
façon concurrence est là pour le coup
par madame hidalgo qui peut elle aussi
se prévaloir d'être une élue qui a fait
l'environnement depuis qu'elle est à la
tête de la mairie de paris l'une de ses
priorités même si je pense que le bilan
de madame hidalgo demi aussi à la
candidature de madame hidalgo on parlait
tout à l'heure un des manuels mais kron
le président qui occupe le terrain
médiatique ces équipes qui oeuvrent on
le voit même pas en secret un qui oeuvre
en vue de la présidentielle et lui qui
ne se déclare toujours pas pourquoi
tarde-t-il autant que y at il un intérêt
pour lui en tout cas le faire
l'intérêt si vous voulez on peut
peut-être le déceler dont finalement une
cote de confiance qui pourrait président
de la république en fin de parcours en
tout cas comparativement à ses
prédécesseurs
bénéficie d'un socle qui est en effet
non négligeable par le fait que les
intentions de vote là aussi pour
l'instant le placent en tête et que
lille à peut-être jugé qu'ils avaient
actées rey a mené la campagne la plus
courte possible pour éviter de se
surexposer et de la sorte d'enjamber
d'une certaine manière le premier tour
en tout cas c'est un pari
vraisembablement qui le envisage de
faire on va voir dans les jours qui
viennent
peut-être la semaine prochaine s'il
finit par se déclarer candidat mais tout
est fait en tout cas actuellement pour
préparer l'opinion publique à une
candidature finalement l' annonce de la
candidature et d'une certaine manière
anecdotique
ce qui est important c'est le timing
c'est à dire savoir quand est-ce qu'il
va se décider à rentrer dans l'arène ce
qui cause un problème quand même parce
que objectivement aujourd'hui pour
lutter à armes égales il faudrait que
ses concurrents puissent avoir un
président de la république qui se
déclare candidat justement vous m'offrez
ma transition puisque rangs on le voit
la campagne de valérie pécresse a du mal
à a réellement démarré faut-il y voir un
lien justement avec la non déclaration
de candidature d'emmanuel nacre ou
alors est-ce que la candidature
officialisée d'emmanuel macron permettra
aux autres candidats dont madame
pécresse à un moment donné de pouvoir
redonner un élan à sa campagne c'est une
question en effet que l'on peut poser
moi je pense que si vous voulez
aujourd'hui la difficulté pour madame
pécresse est que après le rebond dont
elle a bénéficié après sa désignation
après le congrès des républicains ne
s'est pas confirmée au mois de janvier
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que
elle à paris pour une partie des tu
auras de droite comme insuffisamment
différenciante même si elle essaie de se
différencier des manuels macron et que
par ailleurs elle a disons deux
candidats eric zemmour est coté et
marine le pen de l'autre qui eux ont
réussi malgré tout à la peine depuis de
nombreuses années mais eric zemmour
depuis maintenant quelques quelques mois
à mordre sur une partie de cet électorat
républicain qui est un demande
vraisemblablement d'une offre politique
est une offre politique plus frontale
vis-à-vis des manuels macron qui le fait
que peut-être tout simplement n'a pas
trouvé pour l'instant madame pécresse sa
tonalité son registre qui lui
permettrait finalement de de disposer
d'une dynamique de campagne qui la
placerait à coup sûr au second tour car
aujourd'hui à ce stade elle n'est pas
sûre d'être qualifiée au second tour
parce que marine le pen a plutôt bien
résisté ces dernières semaines merci
beaucoup a renouvellé betty rédacteur en
chef de la revue politique et
parlementaire de nous avoir apporté
votre votre analyse